hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical laboratory
workflow the impact of the 3 r's
presented by dr. janine holden we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this webinar
sponsored by beckman coulter beckman
coulter is dedicated to advancing and
optimizing the laboratory the company's
global leadership and world-class
service and support delivers
sophisticated instrument systems
reagents and services to life science
researchers in academic and commercial
laboratories enabling new discoveries
and biology based research and
development for more information please
visit www m i'm kristina jo love lab
roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
low and left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located and the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the c/e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce our speaker dr. janine
holden prior to joining the beckman
coulter team in 2013 dr. Holden was
associate professor and director of hema
pathology excuse me kima hematopathology
and flow cytometry at emory university
school of medicine
in Atlanta Georgia where she ran a
hematopathology reference laboratory
providing expert consultation service in
microscopy flow cytometric
immunophenotyping fluorescence in situ
hebert hybridization Saito genex and
molecular diagnostic she currently
serves as past president for the
international clinical cytometry society
iccs and is actively involved with both
the International Society for the
Advancement of cytometry and the
European society for clinical cell
analysis she is also past chair of the
iccs advocacy committee and serves as
the iccs liaison to the College of
American Pathologists diagnostic
immunology resource committee dr.
Holden's combined deep experience and
diagnostics laboratory management
education and regulatory and
reimbursement strategy is unique dr.
Holden received her undergraduate degree
from University of Virginia her MD from
emory university school of medicine
where she also completed training in
anatomic and clinical pathology and
Hamato pathology and her MBA from
Georgia Institute of Technology please
join me in welcoming dr. janine holden i
will now turn the presentation over to
her Thank You Christy for that I'm very
detailed introduction and thanks to all
of you for attending today's webinar
it's my pleasure to speak to you today
the topic we're going to be addressing
the course is the clinical laboratory
and specifically the impact of what i
call the 3 r's so we're going to go
ahead and get started on this is an
overview of what we'll be discussing in
the talk i'll be coming back these
points as we address them and this first
slide of course is a little bit about my
background which christy is already
described in great detail but just to
say that essentially my career up until
2013 was in academic medicine where i
did both diagnostic hematopathology and
operated a reference laboratory in in
that setting and specifically have a
particularly deep experience in flow
cytometric immunophenotyping
and that laboratory does about 6,000
Leukemia Lymphoma cases per year since
20 beckman coulter i actually have two
roles one is director of scientific
affairs and the other I now I'm ahead
that application support for the
developed markets that is Europe Canada
and the US so we're going to start by
describing the three RS and discussing
in some detail their underlying drivers
so what are the 3 R's well the first one
is reimbursement that is to say how much
money laboratories performing testing
can will obtain whether do it through
getting it from say insurance or a
governmental agency how is it that the
laboratory funds is activities the
second is regulatory and this is
essentially the regulatory framework
within which clinical laboratories have
to operate and the third r is resource
so when I say resource I mean human
resource specifically to those of us who
actually work in the lab so we're going
to get right off with the audience
participation portion of the of this
session there are so the question is
which of the 3 R's do you consider to be
the most important so just click one of
these either reimbursement how much are
you are you concerned about perhaps
about how much money you're getting or
think you will get in the future
regulatory are the regulatory issues
that think may be of concern to the lab
and resource so pick one of those we're
going to leave that pull open for a few
more seconds and I'll take a sip of
water which is there every time I ask
you guys a question I get to a app too
ok so we closed it and we're going to go
to see the results ok very interesting
ah excellent so on twenty one percent of
you feel that reimbursement is the most
pressing issue through the eight percent
feel that regulatory is the most
pressing issue and forty percent feel
your human resource is the most pressing
issues so that is very interesting and
actual information for me as I go
forward later actually we're going to
see what another audience said when they
saw this this slide so I'm going to
continue from there okay so with that we
actually are going to start even though
minority of you actually thought the
reimbursement was the most pressing
issue i am and talk about in some detail
now point out that a lot of people don't
understand how their laboratories
actually get money and that's why I
bothered to describe it in the context
of this slide abyss Hawk rather so that
typically the three ways the laboratory
can get reimbursed for the work that
they do so this is your essentially your
revenue this is your top line the money
comes coming into your lab so one what
one means is fee-for-service there's
also something called capitation and
finally what's called bundling so in a
fee-for-service system each test or
procedure because this also can apply to
things like surgeries or office visits
and so forth on each tests or procedures
reimbursed separately so this is
actually very straightforward when it
comes to the laboratory you know exactly
how much you're getting it paid protest
you know that each and every test you do
get reimbursed and you know that the
more testing you do the more you'll get
paid now so that's that the pro to this
system the Conte abyss the consciousness
system are numerous the first is that
there is no gatekeeper incentive there's
no incentive for the laboratory to do
less testing and perhaps avoid doing
things like repeat testing and so for
that reason it's assumed third-party
payers therefore will just tend to
assume overutilization even if you're
not doing it so plenty of labs actually
do still say oh I just I got you know
two samples within a 24-hour period I
probably don't need to do them both or
if I do I should check but the third
party payers will actually assume
overutilization just because of the fact
there is no built-in gatekeeper
incentive so there is a potential
overutilization to essentially do too
many testing the problem with this what
happens typically when third-party
payers assume utilization is over
utilization is they will actually put in
place limits that although the idea is
to prevent overutilization the ultimate
consequence is that they actually may
limit patient access this can be quite
problematic in certain markets now the
second means you can get oh actually
Formula One to other means of doing it
I'm going to talk a little bit about
flow cytometry because that's where I
have particular expertise I'll point out
that in the u.s. flow cytometry for
assays other than lymphocyte subsets and
stem cell enumeration on baby cd34 is
based on nonspecific stack what are
called CPT codes and so for the first
marker let's say you're running fate say
a 20 marker panel for leukemia lymphoma
you would actually bill 88 1844 the
first marker 88 185 each additional
marker and then depending on the number
of markers who had run you would bill
one of the professional skis so it's a
fairly complicated on the system and
there are particular issues with it
there aren't actually a lot of pros to
the system there are a number of cons
however again there's no gatekeeper
incentive so in this instance the
potential overutilization really speaks
to too many too many markers so what
happens is that third party payers again
we'll assume over utilization and put in
place policies that try to limit the
number of markers that are actually
being run either by not funding or in
some case arguing that you should be
doing fewer markers when of course you
actually should not that's driven by
medical medical necessity the codes
themselves are nonspecific so they are
agnostic to the actual test which is
problematic if you're trying to figure
out why the test was actually
done and it's also extremely difficult
if you're trying to do cost accounting
in your laboratory Perez on a per marker
basis because of course we don't run we
don't actually do the testing as a point
of / more curvaceous now another means
of reimbursement is capitation so under
a capitation system and this is pretty
is typical in a typical of impatience in
the US and many patients are all
patients in some in healthcare systems
in other parts of the world under the
system the tests are not reimbursed
separately the it may be they may be all
linked to an individual patient so you
essentially get a set amount of money
for each patient in the healthcare
system or they may be linked to a care
event and so that's the system we have
in the US for in patients under the DRG
system the pros to a system like that is
that they actually do encourage
gatekeeping and lab efficiency because
the amount of money you have available
to you is is limited and you will
therefore you typically therefore want
to be not doing it excess testing the
cause of course is the lab bears the
financial risk for some reason you end
up having to do much more testing than
the capitation model predicted you may
actually lose money and it is also
possible that the system may limit
patient access as an unintended
consequence
now the third system is bundling and
this is also something we are seeing in
the US now in this case tests are
grouped and these aren't the necessaries
aren't the same test they just as the
the payer in it often Medicare in the US
will simply assume that certain tests
are similar enough that they can all be
reimbursed at the same rate now the
payers love this because it simplifies
their accounting they don't have to come
up with different reimbursement for
every test on the books they can say
well this is a level 3 this on this
particular fee schedule and all of the
level 3 testing gets the same same
reimbursement the problem of course is
that if there's the risk that the test
will be assigned to the incorrect group
this actually happened in the US a
couple of years ago for outpatient Oh
Thomas retesting for instance in which
they were the test was actually assigned
to the wrong group and was consequently
way under reimbursed for a period of a
year on the last financial risk varies
with the cats mix so if you do a lot of
testing that is over reimbursed under
this system then your lab will do well
if you do more of a test that's under
reimbursed within that particular group
and the pair is acknowledged that this
happens then then you'll be at bear that
financial brunt and again there's a
potential for limiting patient access as
unintended consequence so Ashley all
three of the reimbursement methods run
the risk of limiting patient concept
access to testing as unintended
consequence so why are we doing this why
are we limiting access why are we so
what you know why is it that people that
pay for testing is so concerned about
reimbursement and it turns out of course
that there are big picture drivers
behind this we are seeing worldwide
population growth on people are living
longer and as a consequence of living
longer not only do they have a
are they alive long enough and have more
time to consume health care but as you
extend your life you actually require
increased intensity of care you have
longer more time to develop cancer other
diseases like type 2 diabetes autoimmune
disorders because are increasingly
frequent with age and the types of
testing that are being delivered to this
the patient's is is also more intense
you see molecular testing for instance
high complexity ancillary testing
becomes more common with these diseases
and of course the types of care these
patients are more likely to get
biologics for instance if they're
getting having autoimmune disorders or a
safe even cell therapy for some of these
disorders including cancer so the goal
for essentially society overall of
certainly third-party payers is to
deliver more care but keep costs from
spiraling so we don't anticipate that
this is going to change and in fact here
is an example of what's actually
happened in the last couple of years for
Medicare reimbursement for flow
cytometry and the outpatient reference
setting so those CPT codes that I
described before so this is 88 184 which
is the first marker can see in 2004 on
how much the vehement was for in that
particular care setting it actually
trend it up a little bit and then it is
now in 2017 will fall traumatically and
we're actually seeing and we're seeing
this across the board and so these are
actually quite deep cuts the overall cut
for it's a typical case is somewhere
between 20 and 30 markers for leukemia
lymphoma I will if we stay on our
present course will rob seventy percent
relative to the 2015 reimbursement so we
have another question so we know that we
immerse month is sixth day we expect
reimbursement to fall which abused to be
the most effective countermeasure for
following the umber sment so you're
ought you offer at a lab how what's what
part of your laboratory operating
expenditure that you can modify in such
a way that it will actually offset the
decreased reimbursement so your options
are to decrease labor expenditure
decrease your consumables expenditure I
don't give you an option to to decrease
both you have to pick one on or maybe
you are a nihilist and feel that you
can't actually affect either one in
which case you'd say not applicable but
I expect most of you figure that can
either eat either decrease the amount of
money you spend on labor or decrease the
amount of money you spend on some
symbols and thereby hopefully offset
some of the decreased reimbursement okay
so that's great um oh interesting
twenty-three percent of you feel that
you can't actually drive down either
your labor or consumables expenditures
now it's possible that maybe you operate
in a laboratory environment that's
already maximally efficient so we'll
assume that that's the case either that
or you're a bit of a pessimist a third
of you feel that the most effective
means for falling reimbursement would be
free if you could spend less money on
your consumables and then forty-four
percent feel that you would have the
biggest impact by decreasing your labor
expenditure so that's very interesting
information and thank you for that okay
so we're going to move on to regulatory
now for those of you in the audience who
are not currently in the United States
you may not be aware of the of what's
going on in the FDA in October of 2014
the FDA issued a guidance there's
actually two vitam TSA's on around this
but it has to do with what's called
laboratory developed test so most of the
testing that is done in in a clinical
laboratory is in terms of type
test most of those are actually
laboratory developed tests they're
actually not in vitro diagnostics now in
terms of the total test volume delivered
because some of the tests are so high
frequency something like a CBC or say
episode in potassium you know serum
electrolytes or something of course
those are all in vitro diagnostics but
if you look at the broad menu of tests
that are actually delivered most of
those are actually developed on there is
no in vitro diagnostic and a good
example of this of course for me is flow
cytometry with the exception of some
some kits for lymphocyte subsets and
stem cell enumeration almost all testing
is done in the context of laboratory
developed tests and these this guidance
are essentially what is the idea behind
the guidance is to increase the
regulatory burden essentially on
laboratories that are doing this testing
to make sure that they are doing that
they're actually doing the testing well
that they're designing them well and
that they've been correctly vetted and
validated and so forth and there's been
considerable pushback against it so in
it so though generally speaking the any
test you do would be assigned a risk
category and the higher the risk so
that's the higher the risk category the
higher the regulatory burden such that
something that was that might be a
particularly high risk test your
regulatory burden would approach the
level that vendors who have to develop
in vitro diagnostics currently have to
have and as you probably understand the
fact that there aren't more in vitro
diagnostics for some for many essays has
to do with the fact that it's very
expensive to develop them and a lot of
that spent expense is related to the
regulatory burden the regulatory burden
be also
lengthens the timeline it takes much
longer to develop a product if you're
going to be marking it as an in vitro
diagnostic so it's it's expensive in
terms of the money it's expensive in
terms of the timeline and it essentially
keeps these products from coming to
market alright so remember we had the
question about which of the three RS do
you consider be most important and this
was actually I gave a much shorter
version of this talk at iccs in last
month actually and I asked this very
same question the question was which the
three yards you considered to be most
important now interestingly the FDA was
actually in the audience so it's
possible that that drove the the the the
high rate of response to regulatory but
it does actually mirror that the this
audience and it reimbursement was seen
as the least significant and regulatory
and resource resource were both
considered more important so I'm going
to ask another question in your
laboratory what you anticipate with the
impasse on workload of increased
regulatory oversight so now this might
be the FDA or it might be if you're in
Europe for instance on the I would not
be surprised to see an increased
regulatory oversight we're seeing this
change everywhere especially if you're
in the US and you are doing testing
light flow cytometry or molecular assays
anything that the laboratory developed
test do you anticipate in to act on
worth load would be increased decreased
or no change
so you have to take into account you
know more paperwork more admin so forth
oh look at that well not surprisingly
most of you felt that it would increase
your workload some feel that it would
decrease your workload and some feel
that there would be no change but the
overwhelming response is that most
people feel that if they have to that a
higher regulatory burden is likely to
result in increased workload so I have a
follow-up question so which of these
would be the most effective
countermeasure for workload impacts
secondary to increase regulatory
oversight so you well the last option is
not applicable workload will not
increase so if you said you didn't think
it would increase or that it would
actually even decrease you would of
course choose that option your other
options are you can perform fewer ldt so
you wouldn't have the regulatory burden
associated with them the other would be
to perform more iBD's you could increase
staffing assuming you could find them or
all of the above
and of course performing more iBD's is
theoretical assuming you could actually
find an IV d that did the testing that
you needed to do well we can assume that
for purposes of this poll that you
actually might be able to source those
iBD's okay alright so in spite of the
fact that many respondents said that the
workload initially that they thought it
would not that have either not change or
decrease most people feel that did not
choose his options so on all of the
above was the winner people thought they
might be able to make a multi-pronged
approach but performing fewer LD tease
of course we would have an impact iBD's
have available and increased staffing it
gets the last option although certainly
for an option you might have to do it
all right so this brings us to resource
so on human resource so labor is the
most valuable asset in any any lab
certainly but also in any enterprise I'm
anywhere you work if whether you work in
in in a university in an industry and in
retail for instance on any service
organization labor is always your most
valuable asset and this is true even in
safe factories where you've got a lot of
automation that your your human
resources still typically the most
valuable it's also typically the most
expensive as well and today Tim you
think about the labor that you're having
asking staff to do there's a difference
between manual and intellectual effort
so manual labor when it's done by people
is inherently error-prone it's just the
nature of the beast we that's what we do
we're rant we're essentially a random
event generators we're also prone to
repetitive motion injury and this is a
real issue on for people that are any
jobs for long periods of time especially
there's also this very important concept
of opportunity cost what could you be
doing if you weren't type
bedding if you think about the many
things that you could be doing which
include developing new assays you're
doing your juicy continuing education
there are lots and lots of things you
can be doing when you're actually doing
manual work instead now what humans are
really good actually is at is
intellectual effort and so typically
jobs essentially are more highly paid
they're more valued as intellectual
effort increases now in the case of a
medical laboratory personnel med techs
ascp has actually been studying this
question for quite a long time and they
argue and it is certainly true in my
experience and from what I can tell
experience of others that highly skilled
workers in general and certainly med
techs are difficult to recruit and
difficult to read and relative difficult
to retain it's a tight market and if you
try to hire anybody recently on it can
be relatively difficult we also have an
aging labor pool and i will say i find
this quote sort of funny it says
laboratory personnel labor force is
aging a seventy-eight percent faster
rates in the entire US labor market this
does not mean that we're actually
getting old more quickly than other
people which is reassuring it just means
that on average we are aging faster
basically basically means that young
people are not entering the labor pool
and this is a lab personnel overall not
just flow cytometry but all labs now if
we look at at laboratories overall the
vacancy rates due on for all staff
actually vary according to type of lab
and small cytometry labs tend to be
relatively low although most most labs
do reports vacancies but say compared to
phlebotomy or Core Lab our vacancy rates
are relatively low and this is actually
from 2014 2014 was the first year the
back included close utama traces
separate laboratories as a separate
response in there
survey previously they were either
buried in hematology or immunology so
these numbers aren't too bad but we but
when we then look at retiring Raiders
anticipated slow so Tommy retirement
rates over the next five years the
situation becomes versus on dyer overall
for all staff we're looking at eighteen
percent if you're looking at bens staff
seventeen percent anticipate retirement
so this is people that are towards it
towards the end of your career on and
for supervisors it's over one is over
one fifth of the total supervisor
population in flow cytometry labs is
expected to retire in the next five
years which tells us that we are
definitely not I'm not concerned on at
essentially having too many staff that
the labor pools to dilute i'm actually
more concerned about their bank too few
and certainly the fact that many of you
answered resource when asked about the
most pressing what was the most
important of the 3 r's points to the
fact that you also understand the
essentially the looming crisis since in
lab staffing so one answer to ask this
question in your laboratory which of
these options the closest labor
consumables expenditure mix do you spend
more on your staff on labor or do you
spend more on consumables so your mix is
majority consumables fifty-fifty and the
majority labor
and I will say that it's not uncommon
that labs don't know this it's pretty
common that people don't actually have
don't actually see their own their
expenditures all right however most of
you either do have access to that
information or understand that in fact
you spend a lot more money on labor than
you do on consumables for those of you
who don't think you do it would be very
surprising on if you are able to either
you're in a geography where labor is
very very inexpensive or on is in some
way being subsidized so a lot of people
have actually looked at this question I
actually did I locked if you like this
paper because it actually broke it down
into an icicle pie charts and actually
showed on the change from 1991 to 1990
so in 1991 and this is all laboratories
not just the variant labor intense
laboratories that do a lot of laboratory
developed testing so laboratory a
laboratory developed test almost always
has a higher labor component reagents
may be more expensive but relatively
speaking the labor component will also
be very high so in 1991 these were kind
of equal labor and reagents we have
overhead here but people were spending a
little bit more on labor but not an
enormously large larger amount but if
you then move up to nineteen ninety nine
over on the right you'll actually see
that labor has increases sixty-five
percent of the overall effects and
equipment of reagents have dropped to
fifteen percent on and you'll notice
also that the overhead is the state
essentially flat so if we then back out
that overhead number this change in the
labor contribution to your laboratory
effects becomes even more striking and
I'll point out that you even have
equipment and reagents not just reagents
that are in that that nineteen percent
of hiding between behind that
love piece of pie there so it gives you
a sense of just how much money you
really are spending on labor so are so
that if she completes a review of the 3
R's we talked about reimbursement
regulatory and and resource and I'll go
ahead and point out that at the end of
this session we are going to have a QA
and so go ahead and start right you had
a question that you want to ask don't
worry if it oh that is we don't know I
don't know who that's the answering and
asking the questions feel free to post
one if you have any questions about what
we already discussed on because we will
want to want to be having that session
at the end so the next point is actually
going to be discussing this concept to
the eight waste so this may be a new
concept to some of you but to many of
you it won't be because this this idea
is increasingly being used in in in the
content and context outside
manufacturing now she does come from a
manufacturing context the eight ways was
is actually part of on Toyota lean
management on and it's at first you
think well they're ways why do I need to
figure out which one they are well
batrix have helps you to take a
systematic approach to to what your ways
are is it a question of maintaining too
much inventory and the associated costs
are you moving stuff around too much are
you making defective merchandise or
defective products that you then have to
scrap so if we we take the same concept
of eight ways and apply it to a
laboratory suddenly it makes it's a
little bit it's more it resonates so in
this case for instance if I looked at it
look at defects in the setting of a flow
cytometry lab here are some of the
errors that can be made and I'll point
out that many of these have to do is if
that's what there were humans involved
so for instance you can add a wrong
reagent you can prepare a cocktail
incorrect
a you may have Sant a switch the samples
this is the absolute worst error you can
make in any laboratory setting as you
know and of course transcription errors
are very easy to make in the case of non
utilized talent this is considered very
specific type of waste and it's not one
it's one that we that is should never be
ignored so this includes a high skill
checks performing low skill tests and
the fact that is that opportunity cost
new and improved assays go undeveloped
because you were too busy pipetting or
or dealing we're doing inventory
management on here this this particular
one emotion is tends to resonate with
many text the text if you if you're
having to transcribe that's unnecessary
motion if you're pipetting that's a
necessary motion if you're opening and
closing containers and refrigerators all
day long that is unnecessary motion so
when we're talking about eight ways it's
just a very helpful way to think about
your operation and really drill down on
and because sometimes categorizing them
really highlights them for you realize
gosh we spend a lot of time doing this I
wonder if there's a way to get rid of
that now the next thing we're going to
do is actually I'm going to show you
some tools that you can use for
assessing waste so if you're going to
assess your waist in the laboratory and
there may be some of you in the call
right now that are thinking oh we have
no waste in the laboratory and we never
make mistakes as well I'm I hope that
none of you think that all laboratories
make make mistakes the question is how
good you are at catching them and all
and essentially all operations have
waste the even even any company or any
laboratory that thinks they've drilled
all the weights after operation needs to
go back and look at it because you could
always take more waste out and improve
your efficiency that way and typically
improve the quality of your products as
well so I'm in order to identify ways
typically you have to observe you really
have to see what people are doing
simply talking to people about it or
reading a procedure manual will not
usually show you where the waist is you
want to document it so that you will be
able to prove to others that you found
it and also be able to have some to
measure against it it's your jump-off
point you know you know it used to take
us an hour to have to do this task if
you want to be able to say what we made
these changes it does it take us more
time that's it now take is less time
does it take is the same amount of time
and ideally you do want to be able to
identify things that you can quantify
how many minutes does it take how many
steps does it take how many petting
steps how much inventory do you have on
bit on hand and so forth then you all
then once you've done it you want to
prioritize you want to identify things
you think will have the biggest impact
and address them first and this is
typically called an 8020 rule and I'll
show you in a minute how you figure that
out then you want to implement your
countermeasures and then sustain and
track relative to whatever you'd
identify it earlier as a sum as
something measurable you'd be able to
track against so this first step is
identifying waste a really useful way of
doing this on which might seem kind of
useless but tends to be extremely
illustrative is something of all the
spaghetti model or a spaghetti diagram
we have here is just a floor plan of a
workspace this is manufacture and I have
two employees here and we're literally
just drawing them you actually sit there
with a with a piece of paper and you
actually draw their movement and you can
see out where they go and if they do it
again if this guy were to take this trip
again you would draw it again and you
can also measure the amount of time or
the number of footsteps or approximately
and you can also often do that by
counting the tiles on the floor is a
really quick and dirty way of count of
measuring distance or footsteps so this
is a spaghetti bottom model and this is
a graphic a cartoon of a spaghetti model
I'm now going to show you a real
spaghetti model and this is actually in
a laboratory and if you look for
instance this is a would be a pretty
typical laboratory space
you can each of these colors is a
different individual social looked at
the look at the bottom diagram the the
spaghetti diagram that's indicated in
blue that individual spends most of his
time in in one in one area and you could
actually drill down a fist at one area
and you can see they're all the
different strands of spaghetti having to
do with the repeated trips that somebody
takes and this can be very helpful in
figuring out that oh you actually could
by moving something from one room to
another you could actually make it more
efficient now you can also fall instead
of following people you can actually
follow a product in this case would be a
sample typically or if you would say
manufacturing some reagents or something
you could follow them so another way of
doing a spaghetti model is to actually
follow other people or products or
samples of around and see what happens
to them once you've done that you've
actually identified what looks to be a
hot spot you can actually prioritize and
this is called a Pareto chart and prater
chart is a really useful way of
essentially ranking the problem the
issues you've identified the sources of
waste or complaints in this case this is
actually done for is for a restaurant um
and and this can be very helpful in
terms of separating out what is actually
important if you would ask the owner of
this restaurant why customers are
unhappy because he might have said
because he might have gotten a few
complaints to his face about it that oh
it's terrible atmosphere I need to put
improve my atmosphere but if you
actually go and get data and ask your
customers what what they didn't like
about your restaurant it turns out that
many of them felt it was overpriced and
many of them felt they were small
portions and if you then rank these in
terms in decreasing order and then
Ashley what we charted here is
accumulative percentage and basically
when you pass the eighty percent mark
this is that 8020 rule you stop this
stuff you're not going to worry
out right now because it's just not
worth spending time on that these are
expected to have a high impact on in
this case the restaurant that if we add
avella on your overall reduction of
wasting or operation alright so our next
option or next to a topic will be to
look at the streamlined workflows all
right so and this is where we start to
implement countermeasures so in this
case i actually have diagrammed the
workflow and again it's very helpful
this is informed by an earlier spaghetti
diagram and so for those of you who may
not be involved in flow cytometry it's a
laboratory developed test and in order
to do the testing you actually have to
buy single color reagents and combine
them in order to generate results so the
steps involved in this or let's say you
want to do some testing somewhere maybe
not you but some in the lab had to check
the inventory of the central color
antibodies discarded outdated single
color antibodies because they're only
good for a limited period of time and
then document of course you've discarded
those if it turns out you need
additional single color antibodies they
have to be ordered and then once they're
order they have to be received they have
to be inventoried and you have to know
where they are and their expiration date
we've opened them and so forth the usual
good laboratory practice when it's
actually time to do your testing we move
over to the right side of this chart of
this of this diagram as you essentially
have to assemble your symbol color
antibodies and historically many labs
did this and some and many labs still do
you would actually pipette single color
antibodies so less for it so this
particular lab it is doing for
antibodies per tube because they're
doing for color flow cytometry and to do
their particular panel they require 14
tubes and this actually reflects exactly
what i was doing in my laboratory when i
was doing for color flow cytometry my
typical panel was 14 tubes
a lot of redundancy and those for
antibodies per tube so if you look at
this I'm going to anywhere along here I
could identify sources of waste but kind
of around any of the steps in this
process in this case I'm highlighting
this last one this type heading of
single color antibodies because this is
this is actually a lot of work because
it's error-prone as being met as being
done manually it's repetitive motion so
the person who is doing this is having
to actually pipette each of these of
these antibodies individually so so
that's actually a 56 different type
heading steps I'm not counting on
unscrew it you know taking off reagent
bottle tops and putting them back on and
of course is time consuming so let's
look at a potential countermeasure for
doing that and the countermeasure i'm
i'm adding is this one here instead of
having the tech on actually do single
shots instead we're going to prepare
multicolored cocktails of single color
antibodies and so in this case i'm going
to prepare 14 different a different
cocktails and so it's one cocktail / 14
tube so we've reduced the number of
pipetting steps from 56 to 14 so still
quite a bit of us heading but certainly
better than it was before so that's
certainly an improvement or in a color
it green visual management is also a
nice thing to have in the lab but it
turns and it's great because there is
less opportunity for error so you don't
have your not going to make single color
miss hits less repetitive motion and
it's going to be faster however by doing
that about by by adding this steps where
I workflow we've actually created some
additional work as well so we you're in
the prepare these multicolored cocktails
to send will color antibodies in your
own laboratory using wet reagents but
that means you're going to have to
choose see them and in some instances
depending on
at which you're on how many cases you've
got you may be in the setting to discard
outdated cocktails in addition on this
the preparing of multicolored cocktails
assemble color antibodies and so forth
that actually doesn't fix any of this
earlier workflow everything to do with
the receipt of your single color on
antibodies and this part of your
workflow which is trust me quite
cumbersome is still not addressed now
and you say well ok that seems like a
wonderful thing to address but I don't
currently have the resources to do this
is there is there another way to do that
so you could actually look and try and
actually directly fix these problems or
you might be able to fix another problem
and that is we can actually instead of
having 14 tubes we can go to four tubes
and the way you do this is to switch
from a four color instrument to attend
color instrument so they're more there's
more than one way to drill down on the
issue one would be to do away with your
single color what reagents the other is
to move from a four or five or six color
platform to attend color platform so
these are all examples of
countermeasures that you can put in
place to fix your workflow not to move
to this slide alright so I'm going to
award by we're finishing up now I'm just
going to point out that workflow is
extremely important in your lab it's not
very difficult to it's actually not that
difficult to assess and you can actually
simultaneously address all three r's
regulatory the embarrassment and we sort
and resource by looking at your workflow
in typical low-hanging fruit that almost
all laboratories that are doing
especially laboratory-developed testing
can consider is look for opportunities
to engineer out
steps and transcription these are almost
always associated with into play are
very labor intense and they are enormous
opportunities for error on decrease
batch processing where possible bad
processing is something we avoid an
industry I can tell you that and if you
can avoid it in your lab on that is
generally better and anything you can do
to simplify inventory management
inventory management is the is the
hidden time sort of time suck in your
laboratory so anything you can do to
limit that will is going to pay off in
the setting of flow cytometry in
particular on there is something you can
do that we actually address with the
maximize your multi parameter capacity
so if you can actually do fewer tubes
you decrease your labor at the same time
although I wasn't emphasizing decreasing
your consumable cost you by having fewer
tubes you actually have require less
less antibody redundancy and overall
will use less reagent and then there's
actually a concept of stacking markers
so you can actually get even more
markers in a tube and thereby mole
maximize your multi parameter capacity
alright so the 3 r's are closely related
reimbursement regulatory and resource
and you actually can address all three
of them simultaneously by addressing
your workflow so i'm going to stop there
we have a few minutes for questions and
answers so i'm going to open up Christie
you want to handle it from handle this
absolutely and thank you for that
informative presentation dr. Holden as
she mentioned it's time for QA and if
you have a question you'd like to ask
dr. Holden please do so now as a
reminder just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
in the box and click the send button we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay let's get started
our first question dr. Holden do we know
when the FDA's final ldt guidance will
be released oh yeah
so yeah so the draft guidance came out
October of 2014 we don't know for sure
when it's going to be issued but we have
heard that it is likely number of
sources say they expect to have at least
an S version if not necessarily a final
version out by the end of 2016 I will
say when I talk to people of the FDA
they they can't say one way or the other
but they seem to nod their heads
suggestively so we're hoping that by the
end of 2016 we know more about what that
final draft that final guidance from the
FDA will look like and what we're going
to be up against how can Medicare
justify cutting reimbursement for some
tests like low cytometry so sharply ah
well so they can justify cutting a lot
of things based on the fact that they
only have so much money and they need to
suspend it and in a case of flow
cytometry they has a strong feeling that
in some care settings it's being over
reimbursed there actually is an issue
with the cpt codes and this especially
in the case of reference testing the cpt
codes actually had a kind of built-in
time bomb in that too much of the
consumables expenditure was actually
loaded into the licence solution some
incredibly large amount of this process
expenses were actually somehow loaded
into the licence solutions so when they
actually we have the rock which is the
agency that looks at practice inputs
when they look at that they said well
there's no way that people are using you
know a hundred mils of license solution
or actually like five hundred mils of
license solution on and they cut that
and it it cut reimbursement we've
actually been pushing back a lot of a
lot of stakeholders are pushing back on
this on and we've actually managed to
slow down to pay
two cuts but we do anticipate they will
still see them how can we predict the
risk categories for the LD TS that we
currently perform it's good actually in
order to do that we're going to have to
see what the FDA's final guidance looks
like right now we know that certain
types of testing are higher risk and
will have um you know will be assigned
to certain this categories and those are
fentanyl infectious disease testing for
things that are highly infectious and
things that affect the blood supply but
but other than that it's actually we're
not really going to know until the the
new version comes out well dr. Holden if
I adopt workflow improvements that
eliminate labor aren't I putting my own
job at risk yeah you know I think that's
an interesting question of a lot of
people I think when you first think
about well less labor that's less of me
if I work on that type of setting and I
think the key there is to realize that
the amount of Labor availed that pool is
shrinking and that not we don't expect
to have less work we actually expect to
have more work um and so I think
although it's something you might think
about initially it's probably i don't
think anybody is going to be put out of
work as a result of improving their
workflow and actually you'll be able to
do essentially more interesting work
very few of us especially those i know a
lot of people here are in flow cytometry
very few of a one to do more of the low
value tasks we want to do more of the
intellectual tab dr. well then can you
explain the difference between three r's
and lean six sigma okay well three hours
is actually is nothing to do with it's
not part of Toyota and actually I'm I
see the person asking the question of
that is actually not from the US so the
3 r's actually is historically a term
that's used to describe education so
it's actually part of the our lexicon in
and educate so we actually sometimes
uses a shorthand it's actually it's
reading writing and arithmetic only two
of which to actually
the letter R so it was just a shorthand
for the fact that these three things all
start with the letter R so lean and Six
Sigma are on a lean of actually part of
Toyota management style Six Sigma has to
do with how many how tightly controlled
a process must be so if a process is if
errors very rarely occur in a process
that is to say usually some it's very
highly automated that means you actually
have to do less control in order to
ensure that you are doing it correctly
for something that's highly manual
you're going to actually have to have a
lot of controls in place to make sure
that you haven't haven't made any errors
and so in a typical lab doing high
complexity testing if you're going to
have to have a lot of controls along the
way you have them even if you don't
necessarily know because you have
multiple people looking at the results
all along the way so so the three hours
enough is it's nothing official lean and
Six Sigma are widely recognized terms
that are related lean is kind of a way
of getting to Six Sigma when we say
something is six will describe something
in terms of the number of sigmas so
three Sigma's is pretty is essentially
not very well controls Six Sigma is is
very much in control and you don't have
to do a lot of checking at the end of
the process to make sure you've done it
correctly what is the ratio of labor to
consumables today it was noticed that
your graph shows 1999 which was more
than 15 years ago and now there is more
automation available for testing so
demand from labor has decreased yeah and
I wasn't actually able to find so this
particular paper i use because it
actually had that hit compare the two
data points there are there is
literature out there that does um
describe that shows very similar numbers
as recently as say
9 so even though we are getting
increasing automation a lot of
automation is happening in the tat in
the setting of say hematology
laboratories in immunoassay for labs
that do laboratory-developed testing
like flow cytometry there is not enough
animation to have a have a big impact on
it and and it's one of these where I
would actually love to be a to actually
publish data from a flow cytometry lab
on and actually see what those numbers
are is that I could what haven't been
able to find a reference it that
specifically drills down on that so if
anybody wants to send me that reference
that would be fantastic let's see I'm
looking at okay um Duncan uh oh here's
okay I'm asking some other questions so
I'm going to okay all right so crispy a
little guide you up yeah yes absolutely
let's get to these we still have time
for a few more okay dr. Holden is did
but Obamacare affect reimbursements to
hospitals um so Obamacare on has not in
and of itself made of a really big
difference all of the trends that were
that we're seeing we're in place well
before Obamacare on it has not certainly
we don't see it as in and of itself
making a big difference it's more on the
question of how many patients are
covered which of course speaks to you
know the intensive care and so forth
most of the patients that are entering
the system through Obamacare are
actually younger patients who are
generally speaking in better health so
they are not yet consuming that very
high-intensity health care obviously if
you're providing more care in general on
it there's an issue there but it's not
had a direct effect on on the
reimbursement as far as I can tell it
actually has encouraged there were some
other things like meaningful use that
are in
couraging labs to say have electronic
health records in place and so forth but
in terms of actually umber sment that
all of that was already was going to
happen anyway have there been any
discussions of artificial intelligence
improving lab setting decreasing labor
has increasing productivity absolutely
absolutely so on AI is it's actually
kind of one of the Holy Grails in my
particular area in flow cytometry
because we actually have to enter
actually use a computer program to
analyze the data and interpret it and
this question of what we call it sisted
analysis is one that everybody who
doesn't do flow cytometry and sees how
we do it automatically says oh well a
computer could do that for you and then
you have to explain how it is that so
far we don't we're not quite there but i
think we in the not too distant future
are I'm going to see um not unnecessary
automated but for certainly assisted
analysis and of course we do have out
and I automated analysis for some of the
lower complexity assays like stem cell
and lymphocyte subsets we have great
questions coming in but it looks like we
have time for one more let's end with
this one what are the key factors in
your opinion that make it hard for lab
personnel be recruited and retained is
it salary based lack of professional
development what are your thoughts you
know I think it's both on the salaries
actually are not bad I mean considering
for the type of work you're doing it's
not bad however that that labor pool
because typically is so highly skilled
can be recruited by people that are
willing to pay more for instance my
company so that is an issue the other is
you're right in terms of professional
development on you know if somebody
who's on no matter how talented you are
your positions in a clinical laboratory
are essentially you can be a bench tech
you can be in a supervisory role or a
technical
specialist and after that you really you
know there's even a bit of a really
large say university laboratory will
typically only have one overall manager
and then you're looking at going into
hospital administration on so the
opportunity for fractional development
are are not great and on the and part of
that has to do that is with spending
more time doing essentially manual labor
rather than intellectual labor we're
seeing a you know their decrease in the
number of schools on the decided it's
multifactorial but it definitely is
we're not getting as many people
entering the lab personnel work
workforce and they are also by and large
are not as highly skilled coming in we
found that there's that there's an
educated of an educational gap as well
so that's where we are dr. Holden thank
you again for this great presentation
and excellent Q&A session do you have
any final comments for our audience I
just like to thank everybody for
attending this morning this has been a
pleasure and I hope you go back and look
at your workflow thank you once again
doctor janine holton i would also like
to thank our sponsor beckman coulter for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May first 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay we hope you share that announcer
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's slide event that's all for now
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon goodbye